Okay. Hello, everybody. We're going to go ahead and get started.
My name is Steven Josefowicz.
I am an associate professor at Weill Cornell Medicine
in New York City.
And I'll be chairing the session this afternoon and also giving the first talk of
the session. I'm really, really happy to be joined
today by Ross Levine from Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer
Center, who will talk about targeting epigenetic dependencies in myeloid
malignancies, and by Jennifer Emengwal at Columbia
University, also in New York City, who will talk about epigenetic
priming as a strategy for enhancing T cell-directed therapies.
So with an all-New York session, we're clearly seeking
refuge from our perpetual winter there.
With that, I'll just jump right into my talk to save as much time for the other two
speakers.
So as a chromatin biologist and immunologist, my lab has interest in
understanding fundamental epigenetic mechanisms that regulate immune cell
function, especially their characteristic stimulation responsiveness
and ability to encode epigenetic memories.
We, in this regard, focus on what we call signaling to chromatin
pathways, which invokes signaling from the cytosol or
the membrane to select target genes in chromatin with a guiding
hypothesis that there exist dedicated mechanisms that are selectively
employed for stimulation-induced transcription.
We're also interested in what happens next after the resolution
of the initial stimulus. Does chromatin return
to a baseline repressed state, or might
these genes retain specific molecular features or an
epigenetic memory, if you will, of that initial stimulus?
And if so, what form does that take, and what are the functional
consequences for the cells and the organisms that encode them?
And this relates to another part of my research group.
And something I won't say anything about today, but a focus on
epigenetic reprogramming and memory of inflammation in
hematopoietic stem cells and immune progenitors.
And so today, with my time, I'll focus on all unpublished
work relating to signaling to chromatin pathways
in germinal center B cells and B cells
and in lymphoma.
The conventional view of signaling to transcription
is the activation of signaling kinase cascades that terminate with the
phosphorylation and nuclear translocation of signal-activated transcription
factors that induce their target genes.
But this traditional view overlooks what I think of as one of the most
fascinating and important
epigenetic challenges faced by complex organisms, and that is
how signaling inputs are capable of
inducing chromatin state changes at
select transcriptional programs within a cell that
defines a specific transcriptional response to a given stimulus.
While these mechanisms that enable rapid and selective chromatin
state changes are, I think, poorly understood, we, of course, do know
quite a lot about different chromatin states.
For example, repressed chromatin states feature the activity of
so-called co-repressors. For example, polycomb repressive
complex 2 or PRC2, which both reads and
writes the histone modification
trimethylation of lysine 27 on the histone H3 tail.
In a feed-forward processive mechanism,
PRC2 places this modification across broad
chromatin domains and also can act to biophysically condense
chromatin and as such is a really potent
repressor of chromatin.
On the other hand, so-called co-activators also operate
through, at least in part, post-translational modifications of histone
proteins to enable permissive
chromatin biophysical features and activities,
including transcription.
And so, since my lab opened its doors in 2017,
we've had a major interest in understanding mechanisms of
signaling-induced switch-like behavior of chromatin
that drives selective and sometimes oncogenic transcriptional
programs.
And with special relevance to this session and meeting, I just
wanted to highlight the intersection of signaling and chromatin in
oncogenesis, and the fact that
signaling and chromatin factors represent the two most
common gene categories of oncogenic
mutations. I'm just highlighting that here in AML.
Relating to epigenetics and oncogenesis, including
in hematologic malignancies, I think there's some interesting
concepts I just wanted to introduce for the session.
First, an idea of permissive epigenetic
phenotypes, whether driven by clonal hematopoiesis
or tumor microenvironment-derived
factors that could also contribute to clonal
complexity and also make challenging clearing residual
disease.
I'll also emphasize with full disclosure, I'm a basic researcher.
I think it's important that
we continue as a field to focus on fundamental molecular mechanisms
of epigenetics in oncogenesis and
chromatin state changes that
drive permissive states for oncogenesis in order to
design rational epigenetic therapies.
So work in my lab and by many others has demonstrated
that histone phosphorylation can act as a very
potent chromatin switch to activate
chromatin and transcription through dual mechanisms of ejecting
co-repressors and stimulating co-activators.
For example, in my lab, we've shown that serine 28 phosphorylation on the
H3 tail can stimulate the activity of
p300/CBP histone acetyltransferasesAnd
also that serine 31 phosphorylation on the H3 tail can eject the
co-repressor ZMYND11 and stimulate the activity of
the co-transcriptional histone methyltransferase SETD2.
We've had particular interest in these two histone phosphorylation events,
going back many years now to my postdoc with David Allis,
because we identified them to be the most dynamically
regulated or the most induced histone modifications, using
unbiased histone post-translational modification mass spec
analysis in stimulated immune cells.
And that's compared to all other histone modifications, methylations, acetylations,
and so on.
And so before I go forward, I'm going to show you some of
our published work just to introduce the characteristics
of these histone phosphorylation marks.
And much of our early work in this field was performed in macrophages,
so I'll show you some of those data here.
So this plot shows the stimulation dependence of
histone phosphorylation here in resting macrophages.
Histone phosphorylation is absent at the stimulation induced gene.
But within one hour of stimulation with bacterial
lipopolysaccharide, we see this broad domain
delineating deposition of serine 28 phosphorylation.
And this is striking in the scope of this modification.
So it spans this several hundred kilobase
chromatin architectural domain, a feature unusual for a
rapid and permissive histone PTM.
In contrast to serine 28 phosphorylation, serine 31
phosphorylation, while also signal dependent,
absent at time zero and induced by one hour,
strictly delineates the transcription unit of the signal activated
gene, RASSF1B. So it's really a co-transcriptional modification,
and it takes a backstage in this talk this afternoon.
I'll really focus on serine 28 phosphorylation.
So going back several years now, we had a major interest in
understanding the signaling to chromatin pathways and the function of histone
phosphorylation in B cells, in particular germinal center B
cells, because these cells are, of course, functionally critical for defense
to infection and vaccine responses,
because their differentiation and selection is
controlled by really exquisite
sensitivity to signaling inputs, the qualitative and quantitative
inputs that they receive in germinal center reaction.
And,
we found concepts, this domain level deposition
of histone phosphorylation invoked to us, chromatin acting as a
signaling scaffold and perhaps a signaling rheostat that can
sense the quality and quantity of upstream signaling inputs in germinal center B
cells.
And finally, we have evidence that histone
phosphorylation, both serine 31 and serine 28
phosphorylation, are constitutively active and present in high
levels in DLBCL, especially
ABC DLBCL.
And all of this work that I'll present was led by Alexia Martinez-DePaz in the
lab and includes collaborations with Ari Melnick's group and Christina
Leslie's group.
And so one of the first things Alexia wanted to do is understand in an unbiased
way
what types of chromatin, which chromatin states feature this
stimulation dependent deposition of histone phosphorylation.
And so she used a chromatin hidden Markov model to
identify chromatin states and
unconventionally included a
stimulated cell condition,
and also included histone phosphorylation marks.
And using this approach, we of course, were able to
identify the same chromatin states that many others have
described using this and similar approaches.
But the inclusion of the histone phosphorylation marks and also
the
cellular stimulation condition enabled us to discover new
induced states of chromatin. And I'm just going to highlight one of those states
here.
This state, which we termed a transitional chromatin state, was characterized
by the highest levels of stimulation dependent deposition of
this H3 serine 28 phosphorylation, this domain level,
histone phosphorylation.
But what really stood out to us was this state was also defined by
very high level preexisting repressive
H3K27 trimethylation. Again, the PRC2 mediated
repressive histone modification.
And I can show you an example of this here at the Myc locus.
So this shows the stimulation dependent deposition of serine
28 phosphorylation, again, across this very broad several hundred kilobase
domain at the Myc locus. And what I hope you can appreciate is that
the five prime end of this locus, there's considerable overlap with
this large domain of repressive H3K27
trimethylation.
And this coincidence of H3K27
trimethylation repressive modification and signal
activated serine 28 phosphorylation invoked this
idea of a methyl-phos switch. Something that had been proposed
perhaps two decades ago by my postdoc advisor, but really was
lacking physiologic context and specific examples like
this.
And so Alexia set out to characterize
biophysically and enzymatically how histone
phosphorylation might disrupt the activity of
PRC2. And
to do that, she really had to consider all of these
special features of PRC2, as I mentioned, its feed forward
mechanism for repression,
and I'll just briefly describe that.
So the EED subunit recognizes
PRC2's own modification, H3K27
trimethylationAnd this recognition
allosterically activates EZH2, the catalytic
subunit, to
catalyze the H3K27 trimethylation on a
neighboring nucleosome. In this way,
PRC2 has this feedforward mechanism and is a potent
repressor. It also makes these contacts with the nucleosome and
DNA to biophysically condense chromatin.
And so what Alexia showed, and in the interest of time, I won't
show you the data, I'll just point you, if you're interested, to the preprint post
on bioRxiv, and her manuscript that's in revision
now. What she showed is that both histone
phosphorylation events, especially the serine 28 phosphorylation,
potently abolishes all of these activities.
Allosteric activation by EED,
phosphorylated nucleosomes make for very poor substrates for
methyltransferase activity. And using single molecule
biophysical studies, Alexia showed that
poly-nucleosomal arrays featuring histone phosphorylation are
resistant to PRC2-mediated chromatin condensation.
And so in this way,
histone phosphorylation really acts as a potent antagonist of
PRC2-mediated repression, even if the
H3K27 trimethyl mark is still present on chromatin.
And so next, Alexia wanted to study these
concepts in a physiologic relevant cell
ex vivo,
and to compare that to
bulk epigenomics data sets that she was generating by
stimulating
terminal center B cells ex vivo. And so to do this,
she
considered germinal center B cell reaction and wanted
to isolate these centrocytes that are receiving high-quality
immune synapse signals from T follicular helper cells and
follicular dendritic cells in the light zone.
And these cells, when they receive signals, either
are selected to return to the dark zone and undergo
additional rounds of somatic hypermutation and affinity maturation of their
B cell receptors, or receiving especially high-quality
signals differentiate into plasma cells or memory B cells.
And for this purpose, she turned to the Myc-GFP reporter
mouse model, which induces this reporter just for a few
hours after these centrocytes receive high-quality signals.
And so comparing bulk epigenomics data sets from stimulated
germinal center B cells and the single-cell data, what
Alexia observed is that there's a progressive loss of
H3K27 trimethylation within this
chromatin architectural domain featuring stimulation-induced histone
phosphorylation, and that this loss of H3K27
trimethylation coincides with increased chromatin
interactivity, especially at this five-prime end of the Myb locus.
And this is data from
inferred chromatin contacts from single-nuclei ATAC-seq
from multi-ome from these Myc-GFP sorted cells.
And this isn't just true at the Myb locus, it's also true for other
genes or other loci that are important for germinal center B
cell selection, including the miR-155 locus and
IRF4 here. And again, there's a lot of
data here, but I just want to draw your attention to the domain-level
deposition of serine 28 phosphorylation, and that
coincides with these architectural domains, and also with the progressive
loss over the first few days of stimulation
time course of this K27 trimethyl signal.
And that this loss of K27 trimethylation really is most
prominent within this architectural domain that features the histone
phosphorylation and mostly absent outside of that domain.
And so, one more slide on H3K27
trimethylation, and there was a piece of the puzzle that was missing for
us because
histone phosphorylation is very transient and
resolves before the loss of K27 trimethylation
occurs.
Histone phosphorylation usually persists on the order of hours, not
days, and the loss of K27 trimethylation was really
happening, we think, after the first cell division.
And
so, in thinking about this, we
considered a paradigm that's become quite common across different
tumor conditions, and that is the antagonism between two
different chromatin states, a PRC2-regulated
H3K27 trimethylated chromatin state, and an
NSD histone methyltransferase family-regulated
H3K36 dimethyl chromatin state. These states
are really mutually exclusive
and are both present
across large chromatin
domains.
And in instances where there's a loss of PRC2 activity
and/or a gain of NSD histone methyltransferase
activity, what's observed is a loss or a shrinking of these
polycomb domains and expansion of H3K36 dimethyl
domains associated with de-repression of those previously
PRC2-regulated domains,
often oncogenes.
And so, consistent with that model, what we found in
these genes in red that lose
H3K27 trimethylation
prominently is that there's a concurrent increase in this
intergenic H3K36 dimethyl chromatin
state, suggesting that this
gain of K36 dimethyl is locking these loci in an on state
and preventing the return of PRC2, but that histone
phosphorylation was responsible for initially ejecting
PRC2.Okay, and we can also look at
this through
correlating
the full change in K27 trimethylation and the full change in K36
dimethylation at individual loci.
And you can see there's a negative correlation here fitting with the data on the
left and in the upper left-hand quadrant featuring
genes
that lost K27 trimethyl and gained K36
dimethyl are a number of genes that are critical for
plasma cell differentiation
and germinal center B-cell selection
. Excuse me.
And one concept that emerged here is a number of these genes are chemokine
receptors, and I really enjoyed thinking about
a molecular mechanism that could link epigenetic
chromatin state changes, including acquisition of a
locked on state with a migratory potential of the cell
that is encoding that type of mechanism.
And so moving beyond germinal center B-cells, this chromatin switch isn't
just happening there. It's also happening in stimulated T-cells at
important loci, including TBX21, which encodes
the transcription factor TBET.
And this was interesting to us and induced us to look back
in B-cells at TBET, because TBET
has been shown to contribute to autoimmune and aged B-cell
phenotypes as described by Ari Melnick, Pip Amery, and others.
And when we look at this, we indeed see stimulation-induced
deposition of histone phosphorylation in murine
B-cells. And we also see, looking in patient-derived
xenografts with MYD88 gain-of-function and
CD79B gain-of-function mutations, that there's
constitutive high-level serine 28 phosphorylation
at the TBET locus in these tumors.
And then I'll also mention that if TBET is kept
in check, TBET and a number of other T-cell activation
program genes are kept in check or in a safeguarded state by
PRC2 and H3K27 trimethylation, then
de-repression of these genes
might be relevant to
use of epigenetic drugs, including EZH2 inhibitors and
potential synergies with their anti-tumor activity.
And that's something maybe we'll hear more about from Jennifer in the third talk of
the session.
And this is also true in NK cells stimulated with physiologic cytokines at
important genes for NK cells, including IL15 receptor alpha, this loss of
K27 trimethylation at phosphorylated domains.
And so to wrap up,
I've told you that there are a number of critical
stimulation responsive genes,
including oncogenes, that are kept in a safeguarded,
repressed state by PRC2, and that immune synapse
signaling in germinal center B-cells or physiologic signaling inputs
across cells of the immune system induces a
transient histone phosphorylation that is associated with rapid
transcriptional induction of these genes and the ejection or loss of
PRC2, despite maintained H3K27
trimethylation. And what we're currently really excited to be
working on is understanding the rules, the cellular conditions,
and molecular features that might determine whether this transient on
state can be reversed back to this
PRC2 repressed state with the return of PRC2, or it might be
locked on, for example, by mechanisms involving
NSD methyltransferases and
H3K36 dimethylation, which would prevent the return of
PRC2 and the re-repression of these loci.
And just in a final note.
Great. We're on time.
In the context of lymphoma, we're
working on understanding how this chromatin switch is dysregulated
in GCB DLBCL and in ABC DLBCL
with guiding hypothesis that EZH2
gain-of-function mutations, together with loss-of-function mutations in
chromatin activators that are downstream of histone phosphorylation,
effectively raises the threshold for the induction of
differentiation genes and the cellular
phenotypic consequences that these lymphomas get stuck in this
highly proliferative germinal center B-cell state.
In contrast,
activated B-cell-like DLBCL
that we've shown feature persistent
histone phosphorylation,
their phenotypes are driven by constitutive
activating mutations in MYD88, CD79B, and
other upstream signaling components, all that converge
on chromatin kinase pathways that deposit
histone phosphorylation. And in these cases, these genes
are stuck in a constitutively selected
program with high level expression of these growth and selection
genes. And then just more recently, we've been really
excited by the H3K36 dimethyl
results and the idea that these states induced by
NSD
histone methyltransferases could effectively lock these genes on.
And indeed, in the context of mantle cell lymphoma, multiple
myeloma,
and as their gain-of-function mutations in NSD2 or amplifications of
NSD2 that we think might be locking genes
in this on state or
converting signal activated transcription to a locked on state or lowering the
threshold for those types of
activities.Skip that in the interest of
time and just acknowledge the folks that contributed to the work.
I mentioned this work was led by Alexia,
who will be starting her own group in Barcelona
this coming year.
And this has really been a wonderful collaboration with Ari Melnick and his
group. Chris Chin and his group contributed considerably to this work.
Christina Leslie at MSKCC,
and the group at EpiCypher who supported some of the enzymatic work I
didn't have time to show you. And also just acknowledge the whole group, really
wonderful group of people I feel lucky to work with every day.
And thank you for your attention. Happy to take any questions you have.
Oh, and I should have said as
program chair also for the next two talks, questions, please
use the mics. There are people online as well and recorded sessions.
So if you have any questions, please use the mic there.
Hi. Jasmine Kang from Princess Margaret in Toronto.
Great talk. I was just wondering if you've looked at the
relationship between the H3 phosphorylation sites and
TADs, whether they're more found within boundaries or
interiors of TADs or the general 3D structure of the chromatin.
Yeah, that's a great question. So we've done some of that analysis.
What we find is that the serine 28
phosphorylation really does tend to delineate
TADs. So it starts and stops at TAD
boundaries.
And another feature we've seen signal is often highest at some of the TAD
boundaries where some of the signal activated genes are.
So we think there's something special about being proximal to a TAD boundary.
The other thing we're really interested in trying to understand is, do TAD
boundaries change when you go from a PRC2
repressed domain to a, say, a K36
dimethyl more activated domain?
And we don't know the answer to that yet.
What we have shown
is that histone phosphorylation doesn't necessarily
change the TADs, but what it does do
is that it increases the frequency of contacts
within the TAD.
And that fits with what
we've seen with histone phosphorylation relaxing the chromatin
fiber and increasing dynamics of the chromatin fiber.
So we think we're really effectively increasing the probability of enhancer
promoter contacts and dynamics within the TAD, and that's part of what
histone phosphorylation is doing.
Thank you so much.
Yeah. Great.
Okay. If there aren't any other questions, we'll move on to our next
talk and welcome Jennifer Amengual.
Oh, sorry. Ross Levine. Sorry.
Keeping them on their toes.
Okay. And your slide should come up any second.
And here's a water if you like.
Great.
Thanks, Steve. And thanks to ACR for the chance to
participate in this session with Steve and Jennifer.
It's really great to see a whole session focused on hematologic
tumors.
So I'll focus largely on myeloid malignancies
and on the mutations that contribute to them.
And I will
liberally talk about epigenetics and also some downstream
consequences and related pathways.
As many of you know, one of the most important
discoveries in the myeloid malignancies field, and I think in
agnostic cancer genomics writ large, were the discovery of
mutations in genes that regulate epigenetic state,
including chemical modifications of DNA, including recurrent
mutations in DNMT3A discovered by Tim Ley and colleagues,
mutations in the IDH1, IDH2, which indirectly affect TET functionality, and of
course, mutations most commonly in TET2.
We know that these are all myeloid malignancy genes.
They're not specific to any disease.
The second is that they're age dependent.
They're quite rare in pediatric malignancies and
increase in frequency with each decile of life at the time of
diagnosis. And so there's still many questions that we don't understand about them,
including their contribution to transformation.
Are there therapeutic targets
relevant to these specific genotypically defined states, and how we
might screen for novel dependencies in these contexts.
And so my lab, a number of years ago, decided to develop
systems that we thought might allow us to mine for novel
dependencies across myeloid malignancies or pre-malignant
states. And so to do this, we wanted to use a system
which would allow us to culture primary stem
cells, in this case, out of the mouse.
And in those systems, both maintain in vivo propagating
capacity such that these cells would be able to
engraft in a mouse after a perturbation and have some
differentiation capacity. And so instead of trying to develop our own
system, we really tried a lot of systems that in the
literature had been shown or reported to allow
cells to maintain stemness ex vivo.
And the system that really has worked well for us is a system that we
really learned from Jason Butler and Shahin Rafii.
Jason being a trainee in Shahin's lab years ago and now at the University of
Florida, and Shahin at Cornell, where they take immortalized stromal
cells that in many cases have a mirusta-lated AKT, which then you
can take primary cells and culture them ex vivo.
And if you were to, after weeks in culture, put them back in a mouse, they can
recapitulate that culture.And so for us, that was
great for a couple reasons. The first is that we were able to take that system, and
as I like to say, a rotation student in our lab can take the system
and grow primary stem cells in their first three days of their rotation, and we've
been able to, with Jason and Shahin's help, teach many other labs how to
use that system. But the critical thing for us is that really was a
platform. And so what we wanted to do was take this platform that Shahin and
Jason developed and use it as a perturbation system.
And so what we did really, thanks to the work of Michael Wartz,
was take primary stem cells, mutant or wild type,
and basically either do chemical perturbations or CRISPR perturbations, which would
allow us to look for things that might either deplete or enhance the
fitness of mutant versus wild-type stem cells.
And Mike actually was able to optimize this, that we can get anywhere from 50% to
80% editing with a lentiviral-induced CRISPR guide in
primary stem cells. And we can either use Cas9 mice or deliver
Cas9 with electroporation. I won't talk today, but we actually think
lipid nanoparticles delivery is going to be even better in these ex vivo
systems than viral delivery.
And so what this allows us to do is to take primary stem cells and
to screen against a library of targets.
You can't do genome-wide CRISPR screens because at least the math,
if you're getting hundreds or thousands of stem cells from an individual mouse or
pool of mice, you're not going to get representation across 20,000 genes and five
guides per gene. So the strategy we've used is to do library-based screens
of genes of interest, whether it's kino-based screens or epigenome-based
screens or inflammation-based screens.
And so Mike's first screen was relatively simple.
He took mutant or wild type cells for different CH alleles,
Tet2, DNMT3A, IDH1,
IDH2, and a CRISPR library into either
wild type or mutant stem cells, and looked for things that would selectively
deplete mutant stem cells and not deplete wild-type stem cells.
What's nice about these culture systems is we can harvest at different time
points in the culture and monitor depletion over time, and you can actually
isolate different populations. You can look for things that deplete
the whole population, things that selectively deplete in the more immature, or
things that might deplete in the mature population, such that you might, for
example, block differentiation.
So you get different readouts depending on how you do the screen.
And in Mike's work, which is published, which is just the
foreshadowing to the work which will be unpublished, which I'll show from this
slide, he was able to show that we found a new dependency in
Tet and IDH mutant leukemias, which was in KDM3B.
And in fact, this was selective to Tet and IDH, and it was true ex vivo.
It was true in vivo, and I won't take you through the mechanism, but refer you to
his paper that we're able to delineate a relationship between
this epigenetic regulator and the regulation of different genes, including the
thrombopoietin receptor, MPL.
And so that really has allowed my lab to embark now on functional genomic
screens alone in collaboration with many groups in different
contexts. And so the one we really wanted to turn to was a
disease that we've thought a lot about
over the last couple of years, which is IDH-mutated AML, and
ask if we could identify mutant-specific dependencies in this context.
And it wasn't lost on us and many others that thanks to lots of work from many
colleagues in academia, as well as at Agios, and Celgene
and Cervie, we now have approved drugs for both
IDH1 and IDH2 that block the neomorphic functionality of
those mutations. Although those drugs are active with
about 20% to 30% complete response rates and probably
aggregate benefits of greater than 50%, they are not
by any means curative or definitive as monotherapy.
Although I'll point out that the IDH1 inhibitor combined with azacitidine is
quite active in newly diagnosed IDH1-mutated AML.
But our challenge was that there are certain genetic subtypes of
IDH-mutated leukemia that really don't respond well at all.
And in a correlative science paper that my lab did in collaboration with our
colleagues at Agios, we showed a number of years ago that patients that
have IDH-mutated leukemia, that have co-mutations in NRAS
or PTPN11 most commonly, but anything in the RAS map kinase
pathway, don't respond to IDH inhibition.
This has been borne out in a number of studies, and really for us is
vexing because that means that there's a subset of patients with IDH-mutated
leukemia that have this a priori lack of
responsiveness biomarker. And so that really has allowed us to
ask a fundamental question, which was, could we understand two things?
One is what's the mechanism that underlies that resistance?
I will say that's a work in progress.
And the second is, are there unique dependencies in those
leukemias that have IDH and RAS together?
So Becca Gilford, who's an MSTP student in the lab, has taken
this on, and all the work I'll show you today is her work, and she's
taken a bifurcated strategy. The first is
that we've developed a set of genetically engineered mouse models.
Now, the challenge here is that you need leukemias that are
AML with or without RAS, and IDH1 or IDH2 by
themselves don't cause leukemia.
So we basically generated IDH MPML double mutant leukemias
that did or did not have oncogenic NRAS.
And then we developed a set of human models, all in graftable
PDXs, that had the same sort of with and without RAS.
And this allows us to both study in the functional genomic studies in
the mouse and then begin to validate those pathways in human, which is
obviously of important translational consequence.
And so what we were able to show in the genetically engineered mouse model
is that if you add oncogenic NRAS to IDH1 and NPM1, similar to work in femurs
done by Tak Mak, you get a more aggressive phenotype than
IDH1 and NPM1 alone, both in primary and
secondary transplants.And importantly, these leukemias
tend to have less expression of more
immature markers, so you tend to get less of what
we would say is a lineage-negative, SCA positive, KIT positive.
You get less LTHSCs, and you get more expression of CD11b
and Gr1. This, of course, is complicated because it's very
likely that the mature markers are being expressed on some
cells that have immature markers, because we're defining the most immature cells as
lineage negative. So I think one of the challenges here as we move, for example,
from classical flow to spectral flow, is to begin to ask if
this is really myeloid maturation or myeloid marker
expression on an otherwise immature population, which might have more of a
mixed state, if you will. But that's important
because that fits with the clinical observation that we see in RAS
mutant leukemia, and I won't tell you about today, but a lot of work, for example,
by Craig Jordan and his former postdoc, Courtney Jones, now at the
University of Cincinnati with Dan Paglia, has shown that, one, RAS mutations tend
to correlate with this, and two, in addition to IDH inhibitor resistance, you
often get venetoclax azacitidine resistance.
So this myeloid mismaturation state is probably a marker
for lack of sensitivity to some therapies.
Probably not, though, to chemotherapy, I would point out.
And what I will tell you is that if we treat either mouse or
human models with IDH inhibitors, the RAS
wild-type IDH mutant leukemias do differentiate, so
they go from having low expression myeloid markers to putting them on.
They lose their early markers like CD3438 double
positivity, whereas the IDH mutated leukemias, which already have
some myeloid maturation, don't budge. They stay exactly where they are.
And that correlates with the clinical observation that they both don't benefit
with respect to response, and in this case, differentiation is
correlated in the human with efficacy.
We don't know if you need to differentiate to get the response
or it's a parallel marker of response, but it is an important
thing. So this led us on a little bit of a tangent, which is, can
we develop strategies now to target these recalcitrant, difficult to
treat, difficult to differentiate leukemias?
And so what Rebecca did was go back to the lab and take
those isogenic systems, so basically taking either wild-type stem cells,
IDH MPML double mutant AML cells, or the triple mutant
cells that are oncogenic NRAS, and using that stromal co-culture
system, basically do a CRISPR-based library.
And we used a version of a RAS-directed library that David
Sabatini and folks at the Broad had developed years ago, and we both
curated it to only look at genes that were expressed in primary human
AML cells from that library, and we added some other signaling effectors that we
thought might be of interest. One important point here is
that the AML cells, just like the clonal
hematopoiesis models in the primary stem cells, in these ex vivo cultures, we can
culture them for weeks if not months and retain in vivo
leukemogenic capacity. So these cultures do allow us to keep
primary leukemia cells alive ex vivo and retain, we think, the
key features that drive in vivo leukemogenesis.
And so we did this screen in NRAS mutant leukemias.
We compared this both to wild-type stem cells and to the
leukemia cells that were RAS wild type.
And if you do the comparison either way, you get two things.
The first is NRAS came out as a dependency only in the NRAS
mutated cells. That's a good sanity check that we're getting biology that you'd
predict to be true. But the other thing that was intriguing to us was that we
pulled out a couple of genes that we honestly didn't know a lot about.
One, which was ELOVL1 and
SPTLC1. And these are important in
metabolism, and that really got us thinking about whether there might be a novel
metabolic dependency in this subset of leukemia.
So ELOVL1 is one of the enzymes that's a
rate-limiting
enzyme, that whole family, and very long-chain fatty acid
elongation, something that I had literally never thought about until we got the
hits from these CRISPR screens.
And so we, of course, first want to validate this ex vivo result in
vivo. So we took these triple mutant leukemias,
and we CRISPR them with either a guide that just goes against
RoSA or the relevant target. And then, because you can't target every
cell in the leukemia, we sequence over time to look at whether the CRISPRed
cells selectively deplete, and they absolutely do.
And we see this both in the peripheral blood on the left, we see this in the bone
marrow in the middle, and this includes the most primitive cells, which in this
model, the KIT positive cells have leukemogenic propagating capacity,
and they're depleted with respect to ELOVL1 CRISPRing.
If we look in wild-type cells on the left or in IDH MPML
leukemic cells that are RAS wild type, we do not see this.
So this dependency on ELOVL1 in our hands is specific
to whether you have oncogenic NRAS.
So we also have begun to try some therapeutics.
Vertex had actually developed for neurologic diseases, an
inhibitor of ELOVL1 for a number of storage diseases.
And we actually can show that we get very nice depletion of the triple
mutant cells, but not really the double mutant cells.
And we're now doing both ex vivo treatment followed by in vivo propagation and in
vivo treatment. These drugs are not clinically
utilizable because they were designed to penetrate the CNS and
actually achieve something there for those diseases.
That turned out to be toxic in the CNS.
But this does tell you that if you could develop an ELOVL1 inhibitor that did not
penetrate the CNS, it might perhaps be of therapeutic import in these
diseases.
And so we next wanted to ask, given the genetic and pharmacologic data, if we
could get a little bit more on a mechanism.
So we did some add back studies, either with a full-length
ELOVL1 or with a mutation, either in alanine or glycine, that are
known to abrogate the catalytic activity.
And the important point here is that if you add back the full-length protein, you
rescue the CRISPR dependency, but the catalytic dead do not.
So we know that the catalytic activity of ELOVL1 is required for
this dependency.We then asked if this was unique to
ELOVL1 compared to all the other ELOVs, and the answer was none of the other
ones are at all a dependency, suggesting this is very specific to
ELOVL1.
So conclusions from this first part of two are that we have
genetic and pharmacologic assays that reveal ELOVL1 as a
dependency in NRAS mutant leukemias.
ELOVL1 is not a dependency in wild-type stem cells or in
leukemias that have a RAS wild type.
ELOVL1, I didn't show you this data, does synergize with IDH
inhibition, suggesting potentially you might get a combination strategy,
and the catalytic activity is required for this function.
So what's the mechanism that underlies this association between NRAS
oncogenic capacity and ELOVL1 dependency, at least in these
leukemias? And so we know that very long-chain fatty acid
processing is important in a number of biological processes.
One of them is the peroxisome, and the other would be thinking about
sphingolipid to ceramide, and a number of other
pathways. And so we first depleted core
peroxisome members, and the short answer was no dependency.
So we could at least genetically, using the same CRISPR strategy in this
model, exclude that this carried over to the peroxisome.
By contrast, if you hit the core catalytic
members of sphingolipid biosynthesis, either KDSR,
which has no redundancy, SPTLC1 and 2, which have partial
redundancy, we could largely recapitulate the phenotype both ex vivo or in
vivo. This, of course, implicates that sphingolipid and ceramide
metabolism is critical as a dependency for RAS mutant leukemias.
So of course, we didn't know what even that might be about.
And so we went back to the literature and read and tried to learn a little bit
about this. And there's a lot of literature suggesting that one critical
mediator of signaling in cells are lipid rafts.
And there's been a lot of question about whether NRAS signaling and MAP kinase
signaling might be occurring on these membrane lipid rafts.
And in fact, we can show that when we deplete ELOVL1, we get a
modest decrease in lipid rafts, suggesting that this is linked
at some level, at least partially.
And so we went ahead and tried a chemical,
MBCD, which specifically depletes lipid rafts.
This is not a therapeutic, but it's a proof of concept that what happens if we
disrupt lipid rafts, and we get a selective depletion of
the triple mutant NRAS mutant cells but not the IDH
NPM1 cells. So if you dissolve lipid rafts, it is at
least at a relevant dose here, able to selectively deplete these
triple mutant cells.
And so we've gone on to look with both
transcriptomics and with proteomics as to whether when you do
those sorts of manipulations and disrupt lipid rafts or disrupt
ELOVL1, do you show an effect on MAP kinase signaling,
or is it a parallel pathway? And the short answer is that we see
marked diminution with oncogenic NRAS signaling or
PI3 kinase signaling in the primary cells that you deplete
ELOVL1, suggesting that this is clearly
some link between sphingolipid ceramide and lipid rafts and the
capacity for NRAS to signal effectively in these mutant leukemias.
We then went ahead and did proteomics, looking at
membrane versus cytoplasmic. And we can show within the membrane
fraction in proteomics, you get selective potent
depletion of NRAS signaling intermediates in that, suggesting
that the lipid raft's ability to maintain signaling is markedly
disrupted. In this case, using the lipid raft disruptor, we're now doing the
same exact experiments with both the vertex inhibitor of
ELOVL1 and with the genetic ELOVL1 CRISPR guides.
So the conclusions from this part are that perturbing peroxisomal very
long-chain fatty acid downstream processing is dispensable.
By contrast, perturbing sphingolipid biosynthesis, including
sphingomyelin synthesis, is required for these cells.
Disrupting lipid rafts decreases leukemia cell viability and is
additive with ELOVL1 loss. And perturbing this pathway is required for
leukemogenesis. I'll point out that a number of other
labs working in hematopoiesis and leukemia are also making important
observations in this space, John D**k and Stephanie Xie at Princess Margaret,
as well as Courtney Jones, again now at Cincinnati.
And so I think it's an exciting area where we're now seeing a pathway that's been
around forever that might in fact be specifically relevant to genetically
defined leukemia subtypes.
So with that, I'll just acknowledge that all of this work again was done by an
amazing MD PhD student in
my lab, Rebecca Gelfer, working with Maya as a technician.
And you can see the other folks in the lab, including Michael Warth, who developed
this system and is now at Astellas.
We've had help from our metabolomics corps and our epigenomics group and
our colleagues in leukemia, and we'd also like to thank our funders.
Thanks so much, and I'm happy if there's time to take questions.
Glenn?
Hi, Russ. Great job. Is there any evidence about the
sphingolipids being linked directly to myristoylation and
myristoylation of RAS?
We have not looked at this. We've tried
to look with
microscopy at the localization of NRAS
itself and talked a lot to Mark Phillips, who's probably one of the best people who
studied it, and it's been relatively inconclusive.
And he's been a little bit not convinced that we're ever going to get the answer
there, but it's a really good question.
What I didn't show today, and is pending, is looking at
phospho proteomics and PTMs. I've only
shown you the total proteins because that work's not back yet.
This is work in progress, but it's a good question to look at the myristoylation
and/or other modifications of NRAS and signaling intermediates.
Cool
Afternoon. Camille from Guy Sauvageau Lab, University in
Montreal.
I was wondering if you tried to
test model that are bearing both
NRAS mutation and
IDH1 mutation,
deplete them with EVL1, and check whether you can resensitize this
model to IDH1 inhibitors.
So you're saying NRAS plus IDH?
Yes.
Exactly, yes. I didn't show that data, but with the genetic,
if we deplete this target, it does resensitize to the
IDH inhibitor, which also tells you that the
oncogenic functionality of that neomorphic mutation is probably totally
not relevant to this metabolic pathway.
We have no evidence, other than the fact that NRAS by itself is not leukemogenic,
it needs partners in crime, that the IDH mutation is at all
relevant to this. I will say we have a little bit of data as well that some FLT3
mutant leukemias have some dependency, suggesting, again, probably because there's
MAP kinase dependency. So there's a lot to figure out here that we're still
learning as we do this project.
Okay. Thank you.
I am just curious, have you had an opportunity to check the new PAN-RAS
inhibitors and how they would synergize in the context of IDH2 and
RAS-muted cancers?
Not yet. I keep asking.
As we all know, often it's not the PI who does the
experiment. But so in fairness, Rebecca is going to do those
experiments, especially now that the data with that vertex inhibitor is
relatively recent, so then if we can do combination pharmacology, it's a
little better than doing CRISPR plus drugs.
So that work is now ongoing in these models.
It's a good point.
Thank you.
Thanks, Ross.
How selective is the ELAVL1 in this loss
of lipid raft
to NRAS-specific signaling activation
versus other mutations that would activate MAP kinase signaling?
We see it for KRAS mutant leukemia models in cell line
systems. We don't have KRAS the same, like
gems.
And like I said, we have a little bit of data both in man and mouse systems for
FLT3. So we don't think specifically it's only going to be
NRAS, so we think it could be pathways that activate MAP
kinase signaling. But that work is still ongoing, and we're still sort of
unwinding it, if you will.
Thanks.
Tim.
Thanks, Ross. That was a great talk. Tim Ley, Wash U.
So RAS mutations are late, and they're often very small subclones.
So does subclonal size influence the IDH resistance?
Yeah. I would say that
the data I've seen, both from some of our collaborative work
and from others, would suggest that even patients that have small
subclones don't get a great response.
And I don't know if, honestly, I fully understand it because you would imagine that
those patients should have an initial response and then the subclones grow out.
So I think, I don't know what you think, that there's some in trans
effect when there's subclones that are affecting the biology, whether they're
secreting factors. We've tried to study that in unrelated projects and have not yet
figured out. But there's something about RAS not just being late, I think, as you
correctly point out, but that it also seems to allow leukemias to
be pretty aggressive when it's subclonal.
So I think there are effects even beyond the subclone itself.
We just have not yet been able to delineate molecularly what they are.
No, I agree. There just about has to be some non-cell autonomous effect of these
small RAS subclones.
Yeah. And I will tell you that we've tried in these ex vivo systems to tease that
out, and those systems have not been able to find
soluble factors so far, but we're not giving up exactly that question.
Okay. Thank you, Ross. Please join me in thanking Ross for his talk, and
we'll now welcome Jennifer Amengual.
Okay. Well, thank you everyone for getting your steps in to come to the farthest
room in the convention center.
I'm really deeply humbled to be giving a talk here today.
My presentation will be a little bit more translational, I think, than the first
two.
Here are my disclosures. Okay. So T cell-directed therapies have really
revolutionized lymphoma treatment.
Immune checkpoint inhibitors such as Pembrolizumab and Nivolumab are approved in
Hodgkin lymphoma, primary mediastinal, and even cutaneous T cell lymphoma.
CAR T cell therapy such as axicell, brexucab, liso-cel, and tesascel
are approved in large cell follicular, mantle cell, and even marginal
zone lymphoma.
And finally, bispecific antibodies such as mocanotuzumab, blofotimab, and
epcurtumab are approved in follicular lymphoma and large cell lymphoma.
T cell-directed therapies, however, do not cure everyone, and in
fact, immune checkpoint inhibitors in the relapse setting in Hodgkin and primary
mediastinal only lead to complete remissions in about 20% to 27% of
patients. Whereas CAR T cell therapy, even when given in the second
line for large cell lymphoma, lead to CR rates of only 40% to
60% with median progression-free survivals of 15 months.
And bispecific antibodies in large cell lymphoma really have only a CR rate of
40% with a median progression-free survival of five months.
We know though, however, in those who achieve a complete remission with any of
these types of therapies really go on to have a very long duration of
response. So we need strategies for optimization.
And here comes the intersection of epigenetics and immune surveillance.
We know that CREBP influences MHC expression.
EZH2 can influence
markers of T cell exhaustion, and DNMT and
TET2 can impact PD-1 and PD-L1 expression.
So we're looking at some of these over the next few
slidesSo first, we'll talk about mechanisms of resistance for
immune checkpoint inhibitors.
This comes in many flavors. It could start from just
formation of the tumor-reactive T cells with lack of sufficient
suitable neoantigens and impaired antigen processing and
presentation.
It can be from defective activation of effector T
cell functions, such as impaired interferon gamma signaling, metabolic and
inflammatory mediators, and it may be due to
severe T cell exhaustion and epigenetic changes.
Now, it's been shown that histone acetylation impacts MHC expression and
anti-PD-L1 effects. In a study by Michael Green, they looked
at patient-derived tissue and found those with CREBBP mutants
had decreased expression of HLA-related genes.
It's been shown that
when
knocking down CREBBP, there's decreased
HLA-DR expression, which can then be
rescued by HDAC3 inhibition.
And finally, when combining an HDAC3 inhibitor with an
anti-PD-L1, it was shown that there was increased interferon gamma
signaling as well as decreased splenic B
cells with the two-drug combination.
So with this in mind, we've been studying at Columbia a novel HAT activator,
YF2. This was selected from a series or a
library of compounds developed at Columbia University, and we chose to
use YF2 as our lead compound, as it had
selective activity against CREBBP and/or EP300
mutated cell lines.
This compound leads to autoacetylation of CREBBP and
P300, as well as acetylation of key targets such as
histone acetylation in cell lines, as well as patient samples.
But based on previous discussion, we're really interested in how
YF2 leads to impacts antigen presentation,
and we found using gene expression array that there's increased HLA
expression following exposure, as well as in pathways
of antigen processing and presentation and MHC
pathways.
Through flow cytometry across a number of cell lines, both in HAT
mutated and wild type, we found that there was increased both
MHC-I and MHC-II expression following exposure to YF2,
also through Western blot analysis.
And in mice treated with this compound, we found in the spleens there was both
increased MHC-I and II in the B cells.
So we decided to combine YF2 with immune checkpoint blockade.
We treated immunocompetent mice engrafted with lymphoma cell
line A20 and found that the combination was safe and led to
decreased tumor growth with the combination and prolonged
overall survival.
And in fact, in the mice tumor cells, we found that there was increased MHC-I
expression, decreased PD-1 expression, and increased
CD226, indicating T cell activation.
Using spatial transcriptomics, we found that YF2 leads to activated T
cell infiltration into lymph nodes when
it's given in combination with anti-PD-L1, with
increase in
T cell interaction
genes and genes related to B cell immunogenicity.
So HDAC inhibitors have been studied in combination with immune checkpoint
inhibitors. In this study,
we see results in primary mediastinal large cell and follicular
lymphoma, and the combination was really safe in patients with no
unexpected toxicities. And it led to prolonged responses,
especially in primary mediastinal, where immune checkpoint inhibitors are
approved, with 80% of patients achieving a complete remission.
It's been studied in Hodgkin lymphoma, and in this important
study, we find that in PD-1-naive patients, the complete
response rate was 57%, which is much higher than we typically see.
In those who have been previously exposed and were sensitive, complete response
rate rose to 71%, and there were even responses in
those who were PD-1 refractory, with complete responses in 11%,
showing that HDAC inhibition can
really enhance and prime immune checkpoint blockade.
Oops. Okay.
DNMT inhibitors, decitabine, have also been studied in combination with
immune checkpoint inhibitors. And here in this clinical study,
there was a one-to-two randomization between
monotherapy and combination therapy.
And we can see in the combination therapy with decitabine combined with a
PD-1, PD-L1 inhibitor, there were increased numbers of complete response
rates. And then when they studied patients who had previously
been exposed to anti-PD-1 and were resistant, we see that the combination
approximated complete remissions seen in the naive
patients.
And in fact, this translated into prolonged progression-free survival.
Again, cohort two is the resistant patients compared to
those with monotherapy, and the PFS is the same.
They had a clever design in this trial, where they took the patients who had
doublet therapy with decitabine and immune checkpoint inhibitor and
added the HDAC inhibitor quidamide to those patients.
And what they found is in those who had previously responded,
the complete response rate was about 60%, and in those who had no
response or progression of disease following the doublet,
25% had a complete remission. And again, this bore out
in progression-free survival, where you can see the three-drug combination in red
really outperforms the singlet or doublet.
Interestingly, they found that there were increased numbers of CD8 T
cells in these patients with the three-drug combination, as well as
more diverse clonality and expansion of CD8 positive T
cells.Now moving on to mechanisms of resistance at
CAR T cell therapy.
This could be due to CAR T dysfunctions through exhaustion or
just being dysfunctional, loss of antigen on the tumor,
and effects in the tumor microenvironment such as immunosuppressive
cells, cytokines, hypoxia, and low nutrients.
So there's been studies looking at EZH2 mutations and association with MHC
expression and immune evasion, as we're seeing in these patient
samples. And in fact, when EZH2 is mutated, there's decreased MHC
expression in both spleens and mice tumors, as well as decreased
infiltration of T cells.
So with this in mind, Wendy Bagalian and her team looked at
EZH2 priming for CAR T cell therapy and found that
treatment with tazemetostat, an EZH2 inhibitor, leads to increased
T cell
connections with B cells and greater overlap between the
two.
It led to increased secretion of interferon gamma,
cytokine signaling in the immune system, and as well increased MHC
I and II expression in mice, as well as co-stimulatory
molecules. They found when they primed mice
with EZH2 inhibition, it led to
increased infiltration of CAR T cells into the tumor
and led to increased time points between
lymphoma cells and the CAR T cells, as well as
increased surface engagement between the lymphoma and CAR T
cells.
They found that the combination led to prolonged survival in mice and decreased
tumor growth. And this is really a class effect, so this is not
just true for tazemetostat, but they studied velametostat, an EZH1/2
inhibitor, and also found decreased tumor growth when
velametostat was used to prime CAR T cell therapy.
This was also studied in the Rella lab, where they found that EZH2 inhibition
influences cytokine secretion with increased interferon gamma
signaling, TNF, and IL-2.
And looking at bulk RNA-Seq
following tazemetostat priming of CAR T cell therapy, we see
increased inflammatory response and interferon response and increased
apoptosis.
Again, they also found decreased tumor volume, prolonged survival,
and really expansion of CD3 CAR T cell therapy with the
combination.
So this concept was translated to a clinical study by Sam Yemshun
at Cornell, where he designed a study where patients were given
tazemetostat, then apheresis, given their CAR T
infusion, and then given tazemetostat again.
And I'd like to thank Sam for providing these slides that he presented at
this year's ASH.
What they found, they treated about 13 patients with
a number of different types of lymphomas with standard
commercially available CAR T cell products.
These patients were mostly refractory to their last line of therapy, had
TP53 mutations, and very few had EZH2 mutations.
They found the combination was very well tolerated with no increased toxicities and
really the same kind of toxicities you would see in the commercial CAR T
alone.
And they found with the combination led to an overall response rate of 100% with a
CR rate of 77%. At the time of his presentation
at ASH in December, 54% of the patients remained progression-free.
In the peripheral blood, they found that
tazemetostat priming of CAR T cell therapy led to decreased terminally
differentiated T cells, reduced TIGIT PD-1
expression, and decreased Tregs, as well as
increased MHC-1 antigen presentation, increased antigen-specific T
cell activation.
Okay. And finally, we'll move on to mechanisms of resistance for bispecific
antibodies. As we know, bispecific antibodies that are commercially available right
now all rely on expression of CD20 on the B cell for activity.
But CD20 mutations are found commonly in
relapse large cell lymphoma and are associated with poor prognosis.
Dr. Schuster and colleagues published that in patients treated with
mocanotuzumab, most patients had CD20 expression
at onset. However, in those at progression, about
34% showed loss of CD20,
and this was through a number of mechanisms, including reduced transcription,
truncation, and epitope-disrupting factors.
It's been shown that epigenetic modulation may restore CD20 expression, and a
number of studies looked at HDAC inhibitors,
here entinostat on the right, knocking down
HDAC6 as a way to increase CD20 expression.
And in both of these studies, they combined HDAC
inhibitors
with rituximab, an anti-CD20 monoclonal antibody
in mice that were refractory to rituximab and found prolonged overall
survival.
So with all these prior concepts in mind, we decide in our lab that perhaps
we can combine HDAC and EZH2 inhibition to prime
for bispecific antibodies and really increase
CD20 expression and MHC expression on B cells,
increase activation of T cells to enhance the
efficacy of a bispecific antibody.
And here we'll be looking at mocanotuzumab.
And the HDAC inhibitor we used was belinostat, and EZH2 inhibitor
we've studied was tazemetostat.
So we found that the combination really led to increased MHC-I
expression on flow cytometry across a panel of
lymphoma cell lines, as well as MHC-II expression.
And we see this is true also by a western blot analysis.
We found that it was robust increase in both CD19 and
CD20 expression by flow
and by immunofluorescence.And interestingly, we found that
discrete variants of CD20 were increased that are the
specific epitopes that bispecific antibodies
tend to bind to.
We developed a
resistant cell line in which the resistant cell
line had low CD20 surface expression compared to
basal. And we did this by increasing
exposure to mocilatumumab, a bispecific
antibody. And this really only occurred when we
also co-cultured with T cells.
And so with co-cultured healthy T cells and slow increasing
exposure to mocilatumumab, B cells
lost CD20 expression.
And when we treated these resistant cells with belinostat and
tazemetostat, we were able to re-express CD20,
albeit not at the same level as the basal cells, but close
to it.
We were interested in looking at what happens transcriptionally,
and we performed bulk RNA-seq. And again, we found that the combination really led
to robust HLA expression with changes in
humoral immune response pathways.
And integrating RNA and ATAC-seq data, we found using
HOMER analysis that there was increased expression of Oct2
and PU.1 which both influence CD20 expression.
Pathways that were over-represented included those of T cell
activation, T cell-mediated immunity, antigen processing and
presentation, and T cell differentiation in the MHC
complex.
So we want to look at what happens with T cells, and we found the combination led
to activation of both CD4 T cells and CD8 T cells,
and led to increased expression of granzyme A and B, as well as Ki67,
especially in the CD8 positive T cells.
When we combined belinostat and tazemetostat and mocilatumumab
in healthy T cells, there was really no impact on their viability.
However, in the B cells, we see decreased viability.
And when we wanted to look at these effects together, we
created lymphoma spheroids or organoids, that are highlighted
here in green. We treated these with
belinostat, tazemetostat, mocilatumumab, and the combination.
And then we also pre-treated healthy T cells, and we overlaid them
together. And you can see with the T cells and the three-drug
combination, there's really increased infiltration of T
cells with the three drugs. We also found by
immunofluorescence, there was increased touchpoints between the B and T cells with
the three-drug combination.
The three-drug combination here, we're looking at apoptosis, where the live cells
are in green, the dead cells are in
red. And we found that there was increased dead cells
in the three-drug combination with T cell overlay.
So we're fortunate to be conducting a clinical study that was funded through
CTEP of belinostat plus tazemetostat, and we're interested in
collecting peripheral blood from these patients to understand how this drug
combination was affecting the peripheral immune milieu.
And so importantly, these patients that we collected the blood did not have any
circulating lymphomas. It was just really healthy-- Well, not healthy.
These patients have disease, but peripheral blood.
And we found through flow cytometry that there was increased MHC II and CD20
expression following the combination, decreased PD-1, and increased
activation of CD8 T cells.
We performed single-cell RNA sequencing
in these patient samples and found a panel of
immune cells represented. And focusing in on these CD8 positive
T cells, again, we found
increased
signaling of antigen
processing and presentation and MHC II interactions.
We found that there was increased MHC post-combination
therapy, both MHC I
and MHC II, by the single-cell RNA sequencing,
and that there was really robust increase granzyme
in CD8
positive T cells.
And finally, we used differential ligand analysis to reveal
that HLA stimulation led to robust activation of both
CD8 T cells and NKT cells in the peripheral blood of patients
exposed to belinostat plus tazemetostat.
We're very excited to collaborate with, again, Sam Yamshoon here on a
clinical study of tazemetostat priming of mocilatumumab.
We're very disappointed. As some of you might know, tazemetostat recently was
pulled from the market due to increased
secondary hematologic malignancies.
But we believe that a lot of the findings presented are really class
effects and that hopefully these concepts will be borne
out through other
EZH2 inhibitors, such as valometostat and others.
We have a lot of
correlative samples that have been collected on this study, and we're still
interested to see how these drugs affect
activity with mocilatumumab.
So in conclusion, epigenetic priming is a strategy for T
cell-directed therapies in lymphoma.
In immune checkpoint inhibitors, modulation of histone acetylation and DNA
methylation may overcome resistance.
In CAR T cell therapy, epigenetic priming improves T cell health
prior to collection, improves expansion of T cells and recognition of B
cells, and is safe in combination.
With bispecific antibodies, it may increase CD20 expression and lead to T cell
activation to enhance outcomes. And importantly, in all of these studies,
there's been no unexpected toxicities, and the combinations have been
safeFuture directions will be to better define
mechanisms of resistance to best optimize clinical translation.
And with that, I'd really like to thank my lab, especially Ted Perchinski, Serhat
Tolu, and Tony Pazos, our lymphoma team at Columbia,
CTEP, specifically Dr. Pecars, who really pushed along this clinical trial,
our collaboration with Sam Yan 準 , and thanking him for some of the slides and
our grant support. With that, I'll take questions.
Really nice, Jennifer.
So I'll start.
What
is it
that you think defines the specificity of the MHC
genes for either the HAT
agonist or-
Mm.
... JAK inhibitors? Is it the
transcription factors? Is there a chromatin state that's particular
to antigen presentation machinery?
Do you see... And then, I guess a related question is, or do you see evidence
that
there's specific activity of transcription factors that control the
expression of antigen presentation machinery-
We did see that
... like CT2A and LRC5?
Yeah. We did see RFX5 increase,
which can then lead to CT2A
expression. So I think that this is probably not
highly specific, but
definitely will lead to both EZH2 inhibition
and histone acetylation can impact MHC expression.
So it's probably not super specific.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you, Jennifer. Thanks to all of you for coming to the session.
So thank Ross and Jennifer both.
Thanks.